So far, we've concentrated on the major stimulants, but there is one minor
stimulant that is so addictive that it needs mention, and this is nicotine,
which is the active ingredient in tobacco. Nicotine is a colorless, highly
volatile alkaloid liquid. Nicotine activates central nervous system activity
and it stimulates the release of dopamine. Tobacco is the leading preventable
cause of death and disease in the United States and worldwide tobacco use
causes more than 5 million deaths per year. And finally, smokers die on average
about ten years earlier than do nonsmokers. Now, this is something very
important to consider if you are a smoker. So we know tobacco use leads to both
disease and disability, but let's look at some of those a little more closely.
So tobacco youth leads to cancer, heart disease and stroke. In addition, it
leads to several lung diseases, including emphysema, bronchitis and chronic
airway obstruction. In addition, for every one death caused by tobacco, 20 more
people suffer with at least one serious illness from smoking.